hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that has spiffy new
graphics look at these things enjoy them
throughout the run of the program it's
also the show that today is going to
take you through the entire movie year
that was 2022 so you don't have to make
your own memory go jogging it's a
free-for-all the very best flicks we saw
this past year in terms of critical
reception audience praise Yelp reviews
we really cover all the bases here at
Rotten Tomatoes and what a calendar we
had we got fighter jet action emotional
father-son stories Beach football and
that's all just from one movie there's
multiverses extraterrestrials visiting
Earth earthlings possibly ruining other
planets period pieced Predators Airbnb
double bookings and of course Nick
freaking cage Nicolas Cage oh my God
you're so hot it was a tremendous bounce
back year for all of us yearning to go
back to movie theaters week after week
and it seemed like every time we thought
nothing could top that something else
did we have a funny way of celebrating
here on versus we take things that we
love and appreciate and make them
compete against each other for eternal
glory there's no real losers here today
it's just one film is going to emerge as
winnier than the rest so in no
particular order here's some but maybe
not all of the films will be tossing
into the Cinematic Danger Room top gun
Maverick everything everywhere all at
once Barbarian nope Avatar the way of
water Pearl Hustle the Batman RR smile
black panther wakanda forever pray and
scream was that this year uh obviously
lots of movies in contention today and
who'd we get to decide the one true MVP
of 2022 I'm asking I don't know is it me
again all right I'm your host Mark Ellis
and I hope you like me now because in
about 20 minutes it's my job to let many
of you down but what a ride here's how
we'll determine a winner round one box
office round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score round three characters
round four memorable moments and then
we'll do a Wild Card round that could
involve anything from best special
effects the highest chances of winning
an Oscar to creepiest phone located in a
basement somewhere I'll tell you what
what we're getting zany today in the
words of a Batman not played by Robert
Pattinson you want to get nuts come on
let's get nuts and we want to get nutty
with you so however you're watching this
vid leave a comment or hit us up on
social media with your take what was
your favorite movie of 2022 you got it
in your head already maybe a top ten
okay it's time for you to start
whittling you're excited I'm nervous and
if you don't like this face it's the
only one I got mach 10 is in range
film's ready host sweaty flying goats
wailing and into the Rotten Tomatoes
Multiverse we go let's get it on don't
move
round one box office
fun year that 2022 because we wanted to
get back into theaters and see our old
friends popcorn butter soda more butter
so we would have gone regardless but
some of the best movies of the Year also
turned out to be some of the biggest
flicks as well and no I'm not talking
about Avatar's run time well I am I mean
he's going to make a planet load of cash
as well but we don't have the total box
office receipts for our return vacation
to Pandora just yet so the navi will
have to be content with an honorable
mention in this round winning the 2022
box office for the year is top gun
Maverick damn right yeah I'm straight
you got it the sequel that took 34 years
plus two bonus years for us to finally
see was worth the wait it was one of
those films that got new demographics of
people back into theater going mode and
then we all raved to our friends that
you need to see this movie on the
biggest screen possible with the loudest
sound system and once you know it odd
our Pals listen to us to the tune of
almost 1.5 billion dollars worldwide a
number that was further stimulated by a
re-release in December so while it
appears Top Gun part duh should have
this round about box office well in hand
keep in mind it did cost around 170
million dollars to make so there's a
chance that another film could
technically have been more profitable in
terms of return on investment but Tom
Cruise and Company did set the bar well
above the hard deck in round one only
other one film passed the hallowed one
billion dollar total this year can you
guess which MCU movie it was hello there
was none of them they got close though
with Doc strange and his parnassium of
multiverses leading the pack with 955
million dollars followed by Thor Guns
and Roses with 760 million bucks and
black panther wakanda forever currently
sitting on a throne of 678 million bucks
so if it wasn't an MCU film hmm well I
didn't forget about UDC fans the Batman
also didn't cross the bill but remained
competitive with 770 million dollars
which is good for the overall Five Spot
in terms of movie theater cash register
Jingles it was Jurassic world Dominion
that also roamed just over a billion
dollars with only a hundred thousand to
spare minions the rise of group bobbed
its way to over 900 million the Chinese
film Watergate Bridge did over 600
million dollars worldwide and props to
Fantastic beast and Sonic the Hedgehog
for their most recent entries sneaking
into the top ten now you speaking my
language but now let's look at some
smaller size films that made a big
impact with us and turned a sizeable
profit for their Studio Barbarian cost
just 4.5 million to check in but hauled
in 10 times that budget for a 45 million
dollar total everything everywhere all
at once costs 25 million dollars and
spun that into over a hundred million
bucks of gold or crypto or rocks
whatever currency you use in your home
Universe X turn to one million dollar
budget into 14 million the black phone
pocketed 161 million off just a 16
million dollar investment okay so
nothing is going to compete with Top Gun
for total bucks earned but your return
on investment winner is X but in terms
of exponential growth over the initial
cost I'm going with smile wow really
you're going to die okay it does make
sense it was a creepy trailer it made us
laugh and then we got scared and it
would overall amass 215 million dollars
after costing a shade under 17 million
to make so that's what 10 11 12 or 13
times what is budget was soaring even
higher than the fighter jet movie so if
it all comes down to Top Gun against
smile that's ironic because does anyone
smile more than Tom Cruise
[Music]
I'll tell you what made me grin ear to
ear pray and Adam Sandler's hustle they
were released direct to streaming
however so we'll have to lump them in
with Avatar and Glass Onion for
honorable mention but speaking of
basketball you know I bet the Predators
can anchor the low posts they're like
what nine feet tall and you do not want
to take a charge against them
thank you
the good news for both top gun Maverick
and smile is that I'm the judge here and
I'm drunk with power I have the
authority to give them both a point in
round one it's the end of the year
spectacular so let's get a little loose
with the rules and I don't want to upset
anybody and smile they um they don't
take losing well
MAV and the creepy Joker grin movie are
on the board who wants to join them
[Applause]
watch audience score sure money is easy
to come by when you're one of the
biggest movie stars of all time or a
highly anticipated sequel in a gigantic
franchise or a film based on one of
those talking picture books but this
stage will put those feet Hooves Talons
to the fire with a simple question how
did we feel about you after we forked
over some hard-earned cash to Bear
witness the Tomato Meter is a scoreboard
indicating how a wide swath of
professional critics felt the audience
score tells us the temperature of the
regular folks out there who took in any
given movie this round will honor the
Top Gun in both categories and don't
tell me is it actually the Danger Zone
movie okay let's back up of all the
movies we've mentioned so far only two
are rotten on the Tomato Meter and
they're only as low as they are because
maybe their overall franchises need to
pull off the highway and refuel or
recharge I guess the dinosaurs would
prefer we drive electric cars and
Jurassic world Dominion notched just 29
on the TM Fantastic Beasts Dumbledore is
the young Pope also south of fresh at 46
but from there it's all freshness baby
well well done how about a hand for rrr
which achieves the ultra rare feat of
being above 90 percent on both the
Tomato Meter and audience score metric
it's at a 93 with critics tying it with
films like prey and hustle I'm really
excited about this Predator basketball
thing by the way do you want to be in
the NBA
and RR landed at 94 with audiences
matching the score of wakanda forever
that sequel to Black Panther hit 84
percent in the Tomato patch and prey
landed at 73 with the normies but hustle
93 across the board meaning that and RR
now get the 90 and above members only
jackets gold jacket green jacket who
gives this yeah oh now we're looking to
see if any other 2022 film can compete
with those two beloved behemoths
everything everywhere all at once got so
close it's 95 on the Tomato Meter and 89
with the audience so don't go anywhere
stick around Pearl hit 91 with critics
and 82 with the rest of us decision to
leave made noise with a 94 on the Tomato
Meter and an 87 on the audience score if
you like the game memory where you have
to find pairs that match you'll love the
unbearable weight of massive talent I
like that movie too the Nick Cage Pedro
Pascal Rob boasts twin 87 on both
measuring sticks I feel bad for the
dinosaurs and the magic people so I will
point out that while both missed with
critics the masses enjoyed them to the
tune of a fresh 77 and a Rosy 83 percent
respectively so you know there's that
but remember the movie about the f-18s I
didn't know the F's went that high but
the Mighty Wings of top gun Maverick
propelled the highest grossing movie of
the year to a 96 on the Tomato Meter and
a 99 with the audience setting the
standard on both metrics for all the
movies we have contending today are you
kidding me that movie just keeps getting
better and to think Ed Harris wanted to
use drones instead
so once again it appears the Top Gun is
the lead dog but the accomplishment of
that RR and hustle make them three of a
kind in this round they're the only Flex
above 90 on both sides of the veggie
garden before we put this round to bed
Barbarian made it to 92 percent on the
Tomato Meter but just a 71 with the
audience and if you've seen the movie
you might know why have you ever rented
a house for a fun adventure I'll say no
more for now I'm sorry who are you top
gun Triple R and hustle all get points
in round two so now we have four flicks
on the board and Maverick leads the
bunch he's used to that with two points
round three character now we get to
Delph below the surface with the best of
the best of 2022 a year that sadly did
not see another entry in the best of the
best martial arts movie franchise sorry
folks that recurring joke just got
renewed for another season of verses
let's go baby let's go
it's a good cast in those but the fine
films of this past year can compete with
any calendar from the past in terms of
characters and performances so let's go
ahead and get this out of the way first
top gun Maverick is a threat in this
round as well we saw the return of an
all-time Tom Cruise Incarnation plus a
bevy of engaging new recruits to fly a
Dangerous Mission Against an enemy that
we're just gonna call the other side
don't think just do but Matt wasn't the
only comeback story in that film Val
Kilmer gave us an emotional stir as
Iceman and I'll give Anthony Edwards his
Goose credit for being such a forced
ghost presence and Jennifer Connelly's
Penny Benjamin who was mentioned in the
first Top Gun Adventure gets credit as
well but this round is also where the
superheroes can Thrive those movies tend
to get pretty stacked with superstars
and memorable roles so how about we kick
off the proceedings with the world's
greatest detective even if the Batman we
saw in the Batman was still feeling out
his investigative process
Robert Pattinson gave us a younger
grungier Bruce than we've seen in recent
decades or maybe ever and it turned out
to be an inspired casting choice but Zoe
Kravitz's Catwoman was on brand as she
stole every scene she's in Colin Farrell
was so awesome as penguin he got his own
spin-off series and a tip of the cap to
the jolly good Andy Circus and the
frightening Paul Dano as Riddler as well
hey guys as much as I appreciated the
cameos and Doctor Strange and the yucks
plus Christian Bales menacing God
destroyer in Thor love and thunder I
just put the New Black Panther film on a
par with the Batman in terms of overall
cast and performance not only did Angela
Bassett Leticia Wright denigoria and
Company Bring It On they also had the
impossible task of helping all of us
fans grieve and send off the late
Chadwick Boseman with moments worthy of
his talents wakanda forever also gave us
tenad Huerta as Namor a new villainous
maybe not really kinda good from a
certain point of view presence in the
MCU let's talk about nope
us wants to digest there and I'm not
just talking about the scary space
Monster Vacuums consumption habit slow
down chew your food Jordan peel got the
most out of some inspired casting
choices particularly showstopper Kiki
Palmer it was such a pleasant energetic
turn that gave the film some much
appreciated pep in its step the overshot
the open shot Mia goth also stepped up
big for Pearl and X which is some
intense double duty for any one year to
manage may I have this dance Big Ups to
the big three from the OG Jurassic Park
returning to the fold but some of the
best chemistry I saw all year was from
an unlikely pairing the massive talents
of Nick Cage and Pedro Pascal teamed up
to create a laugh Riot that was
surprisingly emotional as well speaking
of emotion I'll be honest I don't know
how or what to feel about a return to
Pandora what 38 years after the first
movie how long ago was 2009 it was a
long time so I really didn't know if I
was going to care about anybody in that
film yes I did oh my God it became a
true family drama missed a backdrop of
Warring factions I cared about the
forest folk the water ones I even felt
bad for a few of the humans who realized
they were in over their head a little
too late to do anything about it and the
Animals the whales the Dolphins or
whatever their long lost relatives are
called on that other planet stole the
show but Marcel the Shell was the
headliner of his film and did not
disappoint so yes we have a ton of
contenders in this round which is about
characters and what better vehicle for a
performer to have than a Multiverse
engine
not you Doctor Strange you did your job
Benedict Cumberbatch is cute even as a
zombie but I'm referring to everything
everywhere all at once the best Stage
for an actor to be on is one that
constantly changes so you can show off
your range and boy does Michelle yo have
that as Evelyn Quan Wang alongside kihai
Kwan's Raymond Wang they're thrust into
a topsy-turvy interdimensional adventure
that also boasts amazing turns from
James Hong Stephanie Sue Jenny slate and
Jamie Lee Curtis as Deirdre ah Deirdre
so for divvying out points for the best
characters and performances of 2022
everything everywhere is a lock simply
for a degree of difficulty and sheer
versatility the top guns and Doc
strangers and Batmans of the world are
top contenders but I feel like wakanda
forever had the highest bar in terms of
characters we had already been
introduced to unlike Maverick or Thor
black panther had to Knight a new leader
and the wakandan collective took us on a
journey that allowed us to grieve while
simultaneously introducing us to a new
underwater power in the MCU so yeah the
points go to Black Panther everything
everywhere all at once and just because
he's the little show that could Marcel
they're all on the board tying them with
smile hustle and rrr and now all those
films Trail fighter Town USA by just one
point
foreign
memorable moments well one of those
memorable moments just happened to me
like two freaking days ago when I was
blessed to be in a theater for Avatar
the way of water and my goodness what a
ride it's gorgeous to look at the Lush
forests and sandals-like Resort
atmosphere on the beach but what kept me
on the edge of my seat and constantly
making sure my 3D glasses were staying
on my nose for the three hour plus run
time was the constant action taking
place epic battles intimate interactions
and uncovering new mysteries on Pandora
was highlighted by thrilling Chase
scenes and so much time underwater I
felt like I needed a SCUBA tank and
speaking of new Mysteries can we just
stop with saying blank year has been a
good year for horror movies they all are
every year brings us dark riches to
throw our popcorn stuffed cheeks in the
moment and keep the lights on at night
for weeks afterwards for smile need I
say anything more no one's that happy
for that walk something's going on there
the black phone had the cardinal rule of
do not go up the stairs and when that
phone rings it's gonna linger with us
long after you hang up Ty West went hard
in the paint this past season with X and
pearl a big highlight we're also the
alligators but we get stepping on nails
something that your host actually did
one time yeah I was making a fort in the
woods in Virginia and um I didn't get
tetanus that's the good news I also
didn't get a dancing scarecrow like in
Pearl so I'm gonna chalk my childhood up
overall as a win
but the best thriller of the Year for me
was Barbarian oh hell yeah
yeah
I get to travel a fair amount for work
and I'm happy at a hotel or an Airbnb
after seeing this film I might want to
lean towards hotels from now on and not
just for the fancy Lobby water and the
occasional ghost Bartender the listing
on this Airbnb said it was a one bedroom
um there were more bedrooms we got out
the tape measure and that's actually a
pretty great sequence the movie does
such a brilliant job of twisting and
turning bobbing and weaving with the
audience and then sometimes just
transporting us to a completely
different situation we're like what
happened is this the same movie how does
this tie in with oh wow cool oh
oh RR what is Cinematic Revelation that
was do you like dancing we got moves how
about tigers got that too and then Roger
just goes full action star in a bevy of
baddies and it's mesmerizing to take in
nope got me more than a few times as
well the alien misdirect in the barn
acted as the perfect setup for what was
to come events which included nothing
less than a crusty cinematographer
getting the ultimate shot and our
protagonist focusing on what's above by
not looking up and it's the one film
this year that may have you
reconsidering if you're signed up to be
in the studio audience for a popular
sitcom hell no kind of like Maverick
rooster in the gang doing Top Gun right
it's a threat to win all these rounds
because I mean it's awesome and they're
really flying these fighter jets the
emotion is there in the scene where MAV
and Ice get to decide one more time who
is the best pilot there's tons of aerial
combat Artistry and yes we did get Beach
football personally I'd go with the
sequence where Pete Mitchell steals an
F-18 to prove this Mission can be
accomplished I also love the theory that
the movie is a dream after the stealth
bomber part because Mavericks actually
died in the explosion when he revved it
past Mach 10. it's worth thinking about
everything everywhere all at once was
similar in that it gave us moments of
Wonder and introspection and also had
the most fun post movie going question
of the year what was your favorite
Multiverse
black panther wakanda forever allowed us
to celebrate Chadwick Boseman in one
scene and then dive into a visceral
battle with an aquatic opponent in the
next the Batman had the coolest
nightclub fight this side of the first
black panther at the unbearable weight
of massive Talent gave us Nick and Pedro
on illicit substances acting like
complete buffoons and it was hysterical
maybe the hardest laugh I had all year
and that includes the fall down rom-com
stylings of bros so if we add it all up
for sheer iconic moments I'm gonna
reward two big budget epics and two
little engines that could the latter
will be everything everywhere all at
once for the Breakneck pace of timeline
jumping and rrr for the sheer kinetic
energy of every sequence and for my
movies that were very expensive to make
but worth the cheddar I'm going Avatar
the way of water took 13 years to get
here after the first one but it's one
long iconic moment and if you think 13
years is a while try 36 years it's been
that long since 1986 first introduced us
civilians to the goings-on at Miramar
specifically in the Naval Aviation
outfit TGM secures another Point dub
away and Triple R gained their second
score of the day and now Avatar avoids
the skunk can I squeeze Barbarian in
there too yeah dude there's just so much
you know underneath the house before you
make the leap from Apartment renter to
home owner it's something to ponder so
yeah it gets the point five points given
out here and now it's time for the Wild
Card round get a leg up as in how do any
of these movies get a leg up on their
competition to seal that all-important
victory for best film of the year or at
least the winner of an episode of this
show so one of the movies that we've
mentioned will join the legendary ranks
of The Simpsons Denzel Washington and
breaking bad as Victorious versus alumni
so in my mind where there's plenty of
vacancy and free HBO there's only one
way to settle this every movie that is a
crew to point thus far is eligible for
the win in this round if you're still
scoreless better luck next year or maybe
you can make a sequel to your quality
film and it will be a top gun or Avatar
and get into the best movies of that
year in the distant future life to me
speaking of C equals it does seem like a
certain fighter pilot a gaggle of Navi
and some wakanda residents all had a leg
up on their competition because we
already LED previous installments in
those franchises whereas the holy
original takes had to learn to crawl
walk and run all on their own without
any assistance from an older sibling so
to even the playing field we're going to
combine the Tomato Meter audience score
and box office from the sequels and
their immediate predecessors average
that out and pit that data against the
newborn flicks we adored in 2022. yes
it's going to require me to do a lot of
math but luckily I have a nap penciled
in immediately after this and for y'all
this is going to be a fun exercise to
see if the part ones help or hurt their
younger siblings chances look it was
either this or our expert researcher
Mark hoffmeyer's idea which was to Crown
a champion for the year based solely on
how many jet ski alligator fog had or
dinosaur chicken appearances are in any
given film sorry Jurassic world Dominion
it just wasn't your year
to recap here's the movie still battling
it out for eternal glory top gun
Maverick smile rrr hustle black panther
wakanda forever Marcel the Shell
everything everywhere all at once Avatar
the way of water and Barbarian for
Avatar I'm gonna spot this new movie a
million bucks consider it a loan pay me
back when you have your totals and we'll
average that out with the first avatar
flick also known as the highest grossing
movie In Motion Picture history so
that's going to be a shade just under
two billion dollars for the average
meanwhile the first Top Gun movie made
and adjusted for inflation 437 million
which will take the franchise down to a
900 million dollar average so while
Maverick gets penalized black panthers
1.3 billion dollar take helps out its
little brother wakana forever as it now
has a billion dollar average that means
that Avatar steals the box office mantle
from Top Gun and strange things are
already afoot and that's what I'm
talking about Avatar will be keeping the
82 percent Tomato Meter and 82 audio and
score from its original outing over a
decade ago but once again Top Gun is
hurt by the 1980s the Tomato Meter for
the OG is a ridiculously low 58 percent
the audience score is a respectable 83
percent but those digits still come up
short in comparison to the new iteration
black panther gets a Tomato Meter Boost
from the first one's 96 percent but that
audience score is just 79 percent lower
than wakanda forever is 94 and again if
you think top gun Maverick is being
unfairly downgraded I'll tell you two
things one you're right but also do we
really care about this sequel if the
first one ever existed it'd be cool to
see Tommy fly planes but without that
emotional connection and backstory I'm
not sure it's the freshest movie of the
year all of a sudden it's a two horse
race for the trophy between Avatar the
way of water and everything everywhere
all at once based on all of the
measuring sticks we have in this round
so how do we make a decision now does
either movie have dinosaur chickens in
it
but everything everywhere has such an
engaging storyline and wonderful
characters Avatar to counter has some of
that and was nothing short of a
revelation as far as visual effects or
seizure I don't even know what I just
saw I just felt like I was underwater
the whole movie and it was awesome you
know what in fact I'm going to
categorize both flicks as one-of-a-kind
experiences but to truly honor the
competitive Spirit between a gigantic
Blockbuster and a smaller artsy film
let's make the deciding factor our old
friend Roi which we as a class learned
stands for return on investment very
good students you all get gold stars
everything everywhere all at once made
over 100 million dollars by spending 25
million dollars to make it can Avatar
beat that according to James Cameron
himself no reportedly this one's price
tag is in the 400 million dollar range
but Jim himself has stated that those
sequels all told could cost over a
billion and the way of water has to
crack a bill itself just to remain
profitable I mean look I want to see it
again and again but I also felt that way
about everything everywhere all at once
and maybe double e gets my biggest comp
supplement of all because I saw it after
top gun Maverick and for the first time
since witnessing my long-awaited return
to the friendly skies I was able to get
sucked into another story though not the
one about the middle age pilot a new one
Maverick may have been my favorite movie
this year but after this video essay oh
I'm gonna start calling these that from
now on I am proud to declare everything
everywhere all at once as the winner of
the versus Battle for best film of 2022.
congrats to the daniels's the performers
and everyone involved regardless of what
Multiverse they're currently residing in
sorry
what did you say so yes there was just
one official Victor here but really any
movie good enough to pass through these
chapped lips into your eardrums is a
winner today as are you dear viewer we
all won because we got to return to
movie theaters in full force celebrate
an incredible slate of films and GAP
about them right here at Rotten Tomatoes
so make sure you hit us up with your
take I'm on social media at Mark Ellis
live you can go to at Rotten Tomatoes or
rottentomatoes.com let your voice be
heard thank you for tuning in to verses
I'm Mark Ellis and a paraphrase Top Gun
and Barbarian you can be my Airbnb
housemate anytime
[Applause]
foreign